u.s president joe biden has made his
first major move against russia his
imposed sanctions on russian officials
and businesses
in response to the poisoning and jailing
of alexey navalny
the kremlin critic was poisoned with a
nerve agent novichok in august and
arrested when he returned to moscow
after receiving treatment in germany
let's speak to our white house
correspondent kimberly halckett
kimberly the first sanctions by the
biden administration against russia
what more details do we know
we're standing by for a press briefing
by the white house press secretary where
we hope to learn more
about these actions what we can tell you
so far from a background briefing with
reporters
is that this will include 14 businesses
and one
entity as well as seven senior members
of the russian government
so we're still expecting to get more
details on those specific
individuals but what i can tell you is
that the united states consulted closely
with
its european union ally to try and kind
of send a message to russia on the heels
of
the european union doing its own set of
sanctions
but this is just the beginning because
not only
are the sanctions in response to the
intentional poisoning the u.s
intelligence say of alexi navalny the
russian opposition leader
and his subsequent jailing but also the
united states is
interested in another action by russia
that is affecting the american supply
chain
notably the hack that took place many
months ago of american agencies which
laid that supply chain bare to russian
intelligence officials so
we expect according to u.s officials
there will be further action
this they say is just the first step in
response to
uh really a changing of the relationship
that is taking place between the united
states and russia
and how the u.s government will proceed
moving forward yeah i
was going to ask you about that what it
signals in terms of the
relationship between the us and russia
are and how different
it will be under the biden
administration
it's a completely different relationship
now
as a result of these actions taken so
early
in the biden administration you remember
the the
2016 hacking by russia this was
something uh that was concluded
in terms of the intelligence here on the
u.s side that russia had interfered
in the 2016 u.s election to benefit
donald trump
even though there was that u.s
intelligence donald trump
refused to acknowledge and even at the
helsinki summit where he met with
vladimir putin
defended russia and accepted vladimir
putin's denials it was a shocking moment
here in the united states and left many
people wondering
what they didn't know about the u.s
russia relationship
as well add to that that the u.s
president donald trump
never in fact took any punitive action
against russia for those bounties that
were paid
for on the lives of american soldiers in
afghanistan so
this is really a different approach
taken again by the biden administration
in contrast to donald trump
and again we're waiting to hear what
more details we'll get from the white
house press secretary
when she holds her briefing in the next
hour thank you kimberly for the moment
of course we'll be
talking to you when we have more
information out of washington kimberly
hackett is our white house correspondent
meanwhile russia's foreign minister says
his country will respond to the
sanctions he cast out on alexia
navalny's poisoning
but didn't mention the kremlin critic by
name
when all those who treated him
thoroughly hide all the facts which
could help to understand what happened
and in parallel instead of honest
collaboration and not
hiding they start to punish us this
doesn't bring
any credit to those who take decisions
and we will surely respond
dimitri babich is a political analyst at
the russian state news agency rocia
sivodnia he says the sanctions won't
have an impact on the russian economy
certainly these actions by the us will
not have any effect
on russia uh especially if you take into
account the fact that
actually the uh the trade between russia
and the united states is very small
sanctions from the european union could
be much more harmful
but so far they were limited to just
several people whom uh the eu accused of
being involved in navalny's case they
are not going to
have a serious impact on economy
actually if you look at the real picture
mr trump was much
ruder and much more course with russia
than mr biden mr biden
is just insulting our president verbally
you know he made that terrible speech at
the munich conference where he didn't
even
uh mention the fact that uh vladimir
putin is the president he just said
putin is you know on the mind in our
institutions
uh so that's just rudeness but uh
it's verbal rudeness trump was rude in
the
in the sense that he imposed on russia
unheard of sanctions
but in general of course this is a very
unfortunate situation because russia
would like to improve its relations with
the united states
and the european union but certainly not
at the cost of letting
someone like navalny who was declared
guilty by the russian court
not for political actions but because he
was a crook
he is in jail russia will not let the
crook out of jail even under sanctions